I think you have something you want to
tell me
[Music]
Harlan started out with a rusty
smith-corona and built himself into one
of the best-selling mystery writers of
all time thirty languages over 80
million copies sold you guys fans I mean
I don't do much fiction reading myself
big fan exactly mr. Blanc is a private
investigator of great renown I read a
tweet about a New Yorker article about
you you're famous the night of his
demise the family gathered to celebrate
your father's 85th birthday and your son
ransom video 10 as well yes but he left
early I think Glenda was upset Walt
would get a little Irish courage and him
he'd get into it with Harlan what
Richard said what are you baiting me
detective attempting to be thorough so
we can figure out the amount of death
you made if someone killed him you think
one of us one of his family
mr. Blanc I just buried my father who
committed suicide why are you here
I suspect foul play
I have eliminated no Sussman Harlan was
cleaning house everyone in the family
has possible motive was halt and
planning on cutting off joy did he plan
to file Walter near the Richard having
an affair that's some heavy-duty
conjecture funny ransom you skipped the
funeral but you're early for the will
reading up your ass very nice family is
truly desperate when people get
desperate but I've come out this is a
twisted web and we are not finished
untangling it not yet Itzik waiting for
the big reveal
all of them lied to me there is one
guilty party behind at all you know
something spill it oh my god
tell me what happened to my grandfather
I think you have something you want to
tell me
you